magnet motor ein motor der ohne
energiezufuhr ewig läuft eines der
dauerbrenner themen die ihr euch in der
web community gewünscht habt und er wird
schon seit jahrzehnten diskutiert kann
das funktionieren und wie funktionieren
elektromotoren überhaupt und kann es
solch ein magnet motor geben jetzt den
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
nicht nur in elektrofahrzeugen sondern
auch in haushaltsgeräten und den
modernen anlagen ist die elektrische
antriebstechnik entscheidend dafür den
energieverbrauch zu senken also wird
intensiv nach modernen möglichkeiten
geforscht sie so energieeffizient wie
möglich zu gestalten jetzt soll es sogar
einen motor geben
der komplett ohne energiezufuhr mit
dauermagneten funktionieren soll
weil sie für elektromotoren kommen
unterschiedliche motor technologien in
frage als standard wird der drehstrom
asynchronmotor eingesetzt doch als echte
alternative dazu erweist sich immer mehr
der so genannte permanent erregte
synchronmotor vor allem in niedrigen
leistungsbereich synchronmotor bedeutet
dass es keinen schluss zwischen rotor
und stator dreh fällt gibt das erkläre
ich jetzt wie etwa bei der drehstrom
asynchronmotor der strato also die durch
spulen erzeugten elektromagnete
schneller als der rote also dieses feld
das sie erzeugen sie werden ständig
zwischen nord- und südpol umgepolt um
den rotor antreiben zu können und das
passiert kreisförmig damit sie ihn
treiben können muss dieses dreh fällt so
wird es genannt weil es sich eben
praktisch dreht schneller laufen als der
rotor also der kern der dadurch
angetrieben wird nur dann kann ein
elektrischer strom durch die spulen
induziert werden
das ist übrigens die motoren
konstruktion die inzwischen am weitesten
verbreitet ist egal ob tesla oder ic
überall findet sich dieses
konstruktionsprinzip es ist einfach und
effizient beim permanentmagnetmotor ist
das anders die permanentmagnete führen
zu einer magnetisierung des rotors das
passiert verlustlos so steigt der
wirkungsgrad des motors gegenüber dem
asyl pro motor zudem brauchen
permanentmagnetmotor weniger anlauf
energie und zeigen außerdem auf vorteile
beim häufigen anfahren permanentmagnete
haben zwei pole nord und südpol und ihre
magnetfeld breitet sich pilz bzw
kugelförmig aus ihre magnetfeldlinien
sind gekrümmt und laufen von nord nach
süd um eine drehbewegung zu erhalten
benötigt man zwei selbe pole die sich
gegenüberstehen und deren magnetkraft
sich ab stößt der gegenpol der mit
derselben kraft eine anziehende wirkung
aus ist muss dagegen im richtigen moment
geschwächt sein um die drehbewegung zu
ermöglichen um diesen pohl abzuschirmen
kann eisen oder verriet eingesetzt
werden doch wie können permanentmagnete
hergestellt werden der energieaufwand
ist sowohl bei der rohstoffgewinnung als
auch bei der herstellung relativ groß
ferromagnetische metalle in pulverform
wie kobalt nickel und eisen sowie
legierungen aus eisen bor oder neodym
dienen als ausgangsstoffe für die
herstellung besonders starker magnete
während der herstellung und des prez
vorgangs wird durch ein elektromagnet
ein besonders starkes magnetfeld erzeugt
dass die magnetisierung ermöglicht dann
wird der preis liegt bei rund 1000 grad
gewinnt hat also verfestigt noch vor
kurzer zeit waren die preise für die
magnete sehr hoch bei für ihre fertigung
teure seltene erden notwendig sind durch
die erschließung neuer minen sind die
kosten mittlerweile wieder runter
gegangen dennoch sind die
investitionskosten enorm hoch und
dennoch kommen sie ihn immer mehr
anwendungen zum einsatz beispielsweise
in haushaltsgeräten wie waschmaschinen
aber auch industriellen antrieben wie
punkten gebläsen und kompressoren die
vorteile der permanent magnet motoren
also noch einmal zusammengefasst sie
weisen eine höhere effizienz bei
niedrigen drehzahlen auf es gibt keine
verluste bezüglich des rotors und auch
der höhere leistungsfaktor ist nicht zu
verachten aber auch die nachteile liegen
auf der hand sowohl montage und wartung
als auch die demontage gestalten sich
schwierig da jetzt gibt es aber noch den
magnet motor ein motor der ohne
energiezufuhr eine drehbewegung ausübt
und zwar nur mit hilfe von dauermagneten
also eine art tapete um mobile dass
durch die spezielle anordnung der sich
anziehenden abstoßen pole dauerhaft in
einer drehbewegung gehalten werden soll
schon in den 60er jahren hatte ein
deutscher maschinenbau behauptet einen
magnet motor erfunden zu haben
der bis zu 20 jahre am stück laufen
könnte
doch selbst im jahr 2006 lehnte das
europäische patentamt den antrag für ein
magnet motor ab sein erfinder wurde 2010
wegen schweren
brooks verurteilt feststehen jedenfalls
magnete können arbeit durch anziehung
und abstoßung verrichten
doch diese muss man auch aufwenden um
sie anzunähern bzw zu trennen
solch ein system funktioniert also
keineswegs als kreis prozess der immer
während energie liefert ein solcher
motor würde immer einen
gleichgewichtszustand anstreben und über
kurz oder lang auslaufen wie alles was
sich dreht und nicht angetrieben wird
vielleicht habt ihr im physikunterricht
mal vom energie erhaltungs satz gehört
demnach ändert sich die gesamtenergie
eines abgeschlossenen systems nicht denn
um einen permanentmagneten zu erzeugen
muss zunächst energie reingesteckt
werden und zwar eine menge aber ja
gehört konkret müssen die teilchen des
magneten gleichgerichtet werden und zwar
durch energieaufwand nämlich in einem
elektromagnetischen feld und das wird
durch strom erzeugt danach kann dann ein
permanent magnet andere magnetische
stoffe anziehen und verrichtet dabei
arbeit und die muss dann auch
aufgewendet werden um eine trennung
entgegen der kraft hinzubekommen im
klartext die energiebilanz liegt bei 0
und aus dem system lässt sich keine
energie gewinnen das system wird stocken
gezwungenermaßen
es gibt und kann so etwas nicht geben
also ihr könnt das ja selber mal mit
magneten ausprobieren der zieht an aber
wenn ich ihn wieder trennen will muss
sich energie aufwenden arbeit es geht
nicht anders die physikalischen gesetze
sind hier absolut eindeutig hin auch
wenn es total seltsam effekt den der
kanten für sie gibt sie haben die
physikalischen gesetzen i außer kraft
gesetzt sie sind einfach und sie gelten
leider auf ein magnet motor
wenn ihr keine videos zu den
entwicklungen in diesem bereich und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dann
begeht ihr die kaputte abo box hier auf
youtube und verpasst kein video denn
über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich garantiert und ihr könnt dann
eben themen vorschlagen einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch mein
schwesterkanal klicks zum social and
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier
klicken aber nicht die genau glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken elektroautos
revolutionäres neues batterie konzept
bis dann
bleibt dran